we've turned the economy around put the
country back to work but what the ifs
show is that labour would borrow
90 billion pounds more i do just want to
say this about the ifs
because here's what they say about our
plans they have given more detail
of how they would achieve deficit
reduction a full description of the
conservatives but they've also said
their words that we are the liberal
democrats the most transparent of all
the parties we've been told by our
westminster politicians we should be
ashamed
of being english well you know what i'm
english and i'm going to celebrate some
georgia's day
the country is not just its economy and
its identity cannot just be read
on a balance sheet there is a choice
it's either the path of continued
austerity or it's the path of investment
under the snp they want to bring down
the labour government
after the election that would be their
mistake to do it once was careless
to do it more than once it seemed like a
pattern on the snp this morning you said
gordon brown was spot on
he certainly was spot on on saying that
there would be a constitutional
crisis for once gordon brown was right